welcome back to the david pakman show
this is luke beasley filling in for
david today while he's away on paternity
leave if you like what you're seeing
definitely go check me out on youtube i
have my own show it's called the loot
beasley show uh but you can just search
luke beasley on youtube and you will
find it
lots of good stuff going down there so
before we get into this next story i
want to warn you it's absolutely
horrifying and heartbreaking an 11 year
old girl who survived the evol day
shooting
spoke to congress testified in front of
congress
about how she watched her teacher she
watched her friend get killed by the
gunman
who went into that school in uvalde rob
elementary
and one of the stories you may have
heard that's just absolutely horrifying
is
she was afraid after the gunman had gone
through shot her friend shot her teacher
that he was going to come back around
and shoot her and so to make it look
like she had already been shot she put
her hand in the blood of a friend
and smeared it all over her so that she
would look like she was also all
bloodied up and and had been hit
let's watch a few moments from this
testimony and then we'll discuss
there's a door between our classroom the
window and then he went to the other
classroom
and then he went
there's a door between our classrooms
and he went to there and
saw my teacher and told my teacher
goodnight and shot her in the head
and then he shot
some of my classmates
and the whiteboard
when i went to the backpacks
he shot my friend that was next to me
and i
thought he was gonna come back to the
room so i grabbed the blood
and
i put it all over me
and
what did you do then when you put the
blood on yourself
just stay quiet and then i got my
teacher's phone
and calm down
what are you telling anyone now
i told her that we need help
and
to sit in the police
in the
classroom
right
or things that you want different what
would it be
do you feel safe at school
why not
because i don't want it to happen again
do you think it's gonna happen
again the entire story is i mean there's
words heartbreaking but you can't
describe
the level of
of wrong that that is no 11 year old
should have to recount an experience
like that no person obviously
but when you see it coming from an 11
year old girl
it's just incomprehensible
no kid should go to school afraid that
they might get shot
that's not something in a civilized
developed country that should happen
i know you've all seen these numbers
before but i'm going to throw up a
graphic of the united states gun
violence compared to other countries we
stand way apart something's wrong
and
we hear all the time from anti-gun
reform advocates
there's all these other things oh it's
mental health it's violent video games
it's the security of the schools and
while i want to address those too
let's look into how we can make schools
safe
and secure let's look into mental health
issues in the country of course i want
to discuss that but we can't ignore
the
massive obvious
in our face issue which is
gun laws
other countries have all of these other
areas that they also have issues with
mental health is a great example of that
lots of other countries are dealing with
mental health problems
but their gun violence is nothing
compared to the united states and that
is because we don't
regulate guns in a common sense way
we're not talking about taking away your
second amendment nothing we're talking
about doing very common sense
regulations and laws that will protect
lives undeniably
now
a lot of times when we discuss this
people will say
i hear
liberals say common sense a lot what do
they mean by that so let's just go
through four big main easy
very popular among the country type
policies that we could implement
universal background checks
red flag laws
raising the age to purchase these
weapons
and waiting periods and that would in
many of the past cases we've saw i've
seen make a difference and it would
prevent future things from happening
uh
going forward
it just doesn't make what any sense why
everyone want to be on board with this
and polling shows
actual americans are on board with this
but then for some reason republican
politicians
specifically are standing in the way of
doing anything
and
i've heard a lot of people witness after
witnessing
these horrible tragedies and then the
inaction by the people in power
i've heard people express the sentiment
of there's no hope it's impossible
i kind of give up
we see time and time again horrible
things happen that you would think would
wake every single
person in power up but it doesn't
and i just want to say while i totally
empathize with that it is
enraging
watching those people who are supposed
to solve issues like this in our country
not do it
and and you do have those moments where
like if it hasn't
happened in the past with all the
tragedies we've seen why is something
going to change now
but i do think
11 year old girls like the one we just
watched
and
all of the young people we've seen all
of the other
innocent lives that have been lost
in
mass shootings they all deserve
us to not give up they at least deserve
that from us
we can't single-handedly make this
happen but the one thing we can
dedicate to each one of those lost lives
and each one of the
people like the one we just watched who
are
forever traumatized by an event like
this
is to not give up we can at least give
that to them
and so while it's gonna look impossible
many days
i beg each one of you because this is
what
causes change to happen to not give up
to keep pushing everything you can
possibly do
to keep
this issue
on the front of mind of the politicians
and of americans broadly
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video